[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILLBACH Let me
get started on lecture 20.
So I'm going to finish
up with what we discussed
last time, which is lecture 19.
And then we're going to
talk about lecture 20,
which is about malleability and
inaccessibility of preferences.
For now, we're going to
talk for a little bit more
about defaults and frames,
and nudges in particular.
So what we left it
off last time was we
talked about default effects.
We talked about
that in particular
in retirement savings.
Defaults can be sort
of setting essentially
in one default option.
That is like, what happens if
you do nothing in a retirement
savings account.
Setting a certain
default option can
have very powerful effects in
affecting people's behavior
in a domain that's really
important in this case,
savings, and in a domain where
traditional economic tools have
not really gone very far, as
in matching contributions,
or any sort of like types of
financial education, et cetera.
It's just not doing very much.
It's expensive to do.
And it's hard to change
behavior, while using defaults
is really powerful, and can
cause large behavior change
or large changes in
outcomes even years later.
Let me talk a little bit about
what is the optimal default
decision regime.
And that's getting
into tricky territory.
We talked about this
last time a little bit.
We'll talk about this
again in the last lecture,
on lecture 23, when
we talk about policy.
So when do you think about
active choice versus default,
so what is active choice?
Active choice to remind you
is like somebody has asked
at the beginning,
or directly asked,
you have to make a choice.
And I'm just sort of forcing
you to do it, more or less.
[INAUDIBLE] the company hires
somebody and in the hiring
package, there is just a form
that you need to fill out.
And otherwise you cannot really
start [INAUDIBLE] company.
Sometimes that's not
really enforceable,
but effectively,
essentially just everybody
makes some choice.
That's essentially active choice
versus default, which is just
like, if you do
nothing, you either
get zero retirement savings,
or some positive amounts.
Now, if people are really
different, then essentially,
active choice is a great thing.
Because if people really
have different preferences,
then we shouldn't just push
them into one direction
or the other.
They should choose.
Everybody chooses on their
own what's best for them.
In contrast, if you think most
people are the same anyway,
and in addition,
people don't really
know what's best
for them, well then
it might be better to just
provide one default [INAUDIBLE]
most people that's
best for most people.
And then most people
will stick to anyway,
because these defaults
tend to stick.
And if people don't
know what they want
or what's good for
them, then sort
of letting them choose
actively might make things
potentially worse anyway.
And so that's sort of
the fundamental trade
off when people have come down
on different sides of this.
And it depends on
your view, kind of,
about sophistication
and so on of customers
who are [INAUDIBLE].
And one big and important
issue with defaults
and with the nudges,
in general, which
I'm going to talk about
to you in a second
is, we kind of want to make
sure that we don't make people
worse off in some
ways by pushing people
in certain directions.
For example, one
thing you might say
is, well, why not set the
default to like 5% or 10%
of retirement savings?
But then you worry about
people potentially over-saving
in their retirement
savings accounts.
And then essentially they
have lots of credit card debt,
potentially, which
might be even larger.
Sorry, the interest rate
on the credit card debt
might be really large.
And people get in trouble.
Or people then withdraw
prematurely, and so on,
which is [INAUDIBLE]
potentially worse for them.
We talked very briefly
about the smart plan,
which again, I'm going to get
back to in lecture 23 as well.
Now I also talked briefly
about sort of default effects
also are quite powerful
in other settings.
For example, in organ
donations, in some places,
organ donations are
explicit consent,
which is like you
have to opt in,
and otherwise you will
not be an organ donor.
In other countries-- and
this is from a while ago--
in other countries,
things are different,
where there is what's called
presumed consent, which
is like you have to opt out.
And otherwise, if
you do not opt out,
you're presumed to consenting
to organ [INAUDIBLE]..
We see essentially
huge differences
in otherwise quite
similar countries,
which sort of shows you
that the default here
can have really large effects.
There's some other examples of
default effects in particular
when it comes to
voter registration,
or green energy choices.
In some cases, in
particular when
it comes to voter registration,
it's actually quite hard
to come with arguments
against setting
a default in a certain way.
Like in some sense,
getting voters
to be registered
when you get say
a driver's license or
the like seems just very
straightforward and--
or when they turn 18, that seems
like a very straightforward
thing to do.
And there, in some
ways, the defaults
can really sort of remove some
barriers and inefficiencies
where we think we should
agree that everybody should
be able to vote if they would
like to, with some exceptions,
perhaps.
And so, if you
can default people
into getting registered to vote,
that seems like a good thing,
unambiguously.
So there sort of default effects
can be really, really powerful.
Now, let's talk a little
bit about-- not just again,
we're going to talk
about this again
in lecture 23, when it
comes, about policy,
but let me sort of
define the issue
and sort of be clear about that.
So you might have sort of come
across the very famous book
by Richard Thaler,
who recently won
the Nobel Prize in
economics, and Cass Sunstein,
called Nudge.
I'll give you the definition
by Cass Sunstein, who
says a nudge is a feature of the
social environment that affects
people's choices without
imposing coercion
of any kind of
material incentive.
So that-- default is
sort of like a clear case
of that, where
essentially you just
say, OK, if you
don't do anything,
I'm going to just
pick a choice for you.
But you can choose, however,
in whichever way you want.
And there is essentially
no material incentive.
But I'm changing essentially
your choice environment
or what people
would call sometimes
the choice architecture.
And there's other
versions of that.
There's simplification,
information disclosure.
Again, these are all things
that are usually available.
People can figure
it out on their own.
But we make it
easier for people.
And one of the big
mantras [INAUDIBLE]
about like, what's the
main thing we should do
to improve people's behavior?
Dick Thaler would often say,
make it easy for people.
Essentially, people are often--
and he said that about
himself-- people are lazy.
And they make simple choices.
And if you make it easy for
them to make the right choice,
they will be more likely to
make good choices for them.
There's some other things
like warnings, reminders.
Notice for reminders, for
example, again, you already
have the information
that somebody gave it
to you previously.
So really it's only like
if you have memory issues,
that might be useful for you.
There's no material
incentives or [INAUDIBLE]..
Use of social norms.
That would be things like I'm
telling you all of your friends
did x.
Now would you like to do x or y?
Or I can send you letters
and say your neighbors used
so much energy, and you use
more energy than your neighbor.
And then I put like a sad
face next to it, or something.
And then you might feel
bad about it because
of social norms, and sort
of reduce your energy usage,
which people have in fact done.
You can also like increase
ease and convenience.
This is exactly what like
[INAUDIBLE] convenience.
That's exactly what
Dick Thaler would say.
Those are things
like, for example, I
can put Snickers bars next to
the counter at the cashier.
Or I can put apples next to it.
And people are more
likely to buy apples
when it's easy or
simple or when they're
reminded of eating apples.
And they're more likely to
eat Snickers bars essentially
if [INAUDIBLE] to them.
To the extent that
you want people
to make what one might
think of as good choices,
making it easy for them to make
the good choice without sort
of restricting
anybody's choice sets
or coercing them in any
way is considered a nudge.
And then there's also some
things about framing of choices
as in gains versus losses,
in terms of their contracts.
Any questions on this?
OK.
So then let me give
you, briefly, sort of--
and again, we're
going to get back
to all of this in lecture 23.
But let me briefly
sort of give you
a couple of examples
of nudges in some cases
where it's pretty clear that
some nudges are a good idea.
So one thing that we
talked about quite
a bit already when it
comes to procrastination
or self-control problems present
bias, or [? losing focus ?]
is the health domain, and
what people and in particular,
individuals and society
often have aligned goals,
where individuals often
want behavioral change.
They want to
improve their diets,
increase physical activity,
stop smoking, get vaccinated,
use less energy, and so on.
And often, there are societal
costs of these behaviors,
or lack of those behaviors.
Sometimes there's externalities
from smoking or getting or not
getting vaccinated.
Sometimes [INAUDIBLE]
health care costs and the
like from obesity and so on,
where it's bad for everybody
if the population is sick.
So these goals are now aligned.
And the social
planner might want
people to improve their diet, or
the government might want that,
or might want to reduce
smoking and so on.
But individuals, as
we saw previously,
often fail to follow through.
And sort of often, education
and information interventions
are often ineffective.
Even price interventions
are often ineffective,
or in the sense of
like increasing prices,
or incentivizing people,
it doesn't always work.
Plus, it's quite
expensive to do.
So one natural question
you might want to ask
is, can we use some nudges to
align intentions and actions?
And the reason why this is
really popular, in particular,
among governments, is that
it's really cheap to do this.
So it's actually sending
some reminders or the like
or providing information
in one way or the other,
is essentially free.
And if governments don't
have a lot of money,
that's an easy thing
to do as opposed
to paying people, which is
quite expensive in many cases.
So here's an example of a
free intervention which is
about flu shot communications.
This is a study by Katy Milkman
and co-authors from 2011.
So here, the goal
of the intervention
is to get people to sign up,
or to actually get flu shots.
So the control group got
an informational mailing.
I'll show you this in a second.
The treatment group got the
same, plus an encouragement
to make a date plan.
And the treatment group got
the same plus make a date plan,
and a time plan.
Let me show you what
this looks like.
So here's the control condition.
This is just an
informational mailing.
It's saying here, the company--
this is a company
trying to do this--
is holding a free
flu shot clinic.
And companies very much want
their workers to get flu shots,
because that reduces
essentially sort of sick days.
If everybody gets
their flu shot,
not only are they healthier and
it's probably good for them.
They're like less at risk of
dying and infecting each other,
or just being sick.
But it's also good
for the company,
because the company now gets
workers to actually show up
more, and have fewer sick days.
So here's sort of the
control condition.
It looks like a perfectly
reasonable letter,
where you say, here is these
days, on which you can sign up.
And you are informed
about the dates and times
of the workplace flu clinic.
Now, the treatment condition
is the date plan condition,
which essentially is
asking people to--
or invite people to
choose a concrete date
for getting a flu vaccine.
And the rest of the
information [? mailer ?]
is exactly the same.
So essentially, that's
just asking people,
pick a day of the week and a
month, or a month and a day,
and a day of week, and
just write it down.
And presumably, that also
then encourages people
to put it into their
calendar or the like
and sort of acts as
some form of a reminder.
Notice, there's
no incentive here.
There's no financial incentives.
There's no coercion and so on.
It's just saying why don't
you just pick a day right now.
Just have a look, check your
calendar, and just figure out.
Make a plan for this.
And the second condition is
then make a date and a time plan
condition, which is
to say, why don't you
also pick a time, which
is even more concrete.
That would be Monday,
October 26, at like 9:00 AM
or whenever I'm going to go.
Presumably, that also
encourages people
to put it into their calendar.
Now what you then get
in this experiment--
it is a very simple experiment.
You get, when you
just send a letter,
33% actually get the flu shot.
When you also send
a date plan, 34%.
And when you send a date plan
and a time plan, it's 37%.
Now, these effects
are a little bit
underwhelming in the sense
they're kind of small.
It's like 1.6 percentage points
at 4.2 percentage points.
And in relative terms
that's not huge effect.
But notice what's
beautiful about here
is that the costs
are essentially zero.
So in some sense, if you value
additional flu shot adherence,
if you value more people
getting flu shots, then a 4.2
percentage points increase,
which is about like a 10%
or whatever, 11%,
12% or something
increase relative to the
control group, that's
quite a bit of an
increase for something
that's essentially free.
So the cost effectiveness
of this is, of course, very,
very high.
Because it's essentially
free, or maybe
it cost somebody a few
minutes to sort of write this
down, or design the sheet.
But really it costs
exactly the same
to send the sheet
here on the left
versus the sheet
here on the right.
So that's kind of an example
of a win-win kind of situation
where we make things
essentially more effective.
It's not really hurting anybody,
and it's cheap and free to do.
And so everybody is happy.
And it's sort of uncontroversial
in the sense of nobody
would argue that
this is a bad thing.
Of course, some
people might sort of
have some concerns about
the flu shots themselves,
which I don't think there's any
actual evidence against that
as far as I know.
But that's sort of an
example where we say, look,
this is very cheap to do.
So presumably you should sort
of pick the right mailing,
or the right design, if I'm
mailing, to encourage people
to do desirable things, at least
from the company's perspective,
while also preserving
people's freedom,
not spending any money, but
also not encouraging anybody.
Any questions on this?
OK.
So here's another example
of a similar intervention,
which is signing up for FAFSA.
This is a paper by
Bettinger et al.
in 2009, where essentially,
people were provided
free additional assistance
in completing and filing
applications for
college financial aid.
This is FAFSA, the
financial aid for college.
And it really increased
college enrollment--
not only FAFSA completion,
but also college enrollment.
And there's sort of
different conditions.
One is control versus just
providing people information
only.
Here's [INAUDIBLE]
information of like you could
get some FAFSA help and so on.
But it seems to
be really what you
need is some additional
assistance of completing
and filing this application.
Just somebody essentially
walking you through the filing
has a huge impact.
There's a bit of a question of,
is that really just a nudge,
or is it like a more
powerful intervention.
But it's a really
minor intervention
where some people just
need some level of help
in filling out this form.
And it has pretty
large effects, if you
look at the FAFSA
[INAUDIBLE] completion
of these forms, reasonably large
effect on college enrollment.
And you might sort of think this
is a hugely important choice,
and sort of if you get people
to make that really big change,
that's pretty remarkable for
doing some very simple things.
[INAUDIBLE] help me complete
and fill out a simple form,
something that you
could have done anyway.
So, and here again, so this is
a relatively cheap thing to do.
And it's essentially
equivalent to the impact
of several thousands of
dollars of education subsidy.
So if you wanted to essentially
pay people to go to college,
[INAUDIBLE]
subsidize that, which
you might want to do for
other reasons anyway,
one key issue with that is
that not only is it perhaps not
particularly effective,
but also you're
going to pay a lot of
for marginal people.
You're going to pay a
lot of people who would
have gone to college anyway.
You're going to pay the subsidy.
So if you have a low budget,
that's really tough to do.
And sort of then
there's not a lot of--
the cost effectiveness
tends to be very low.
Because you have
essentially a low impact,
but like really high costs.
And you can read about this
more in the link that I had.
But essentially the
bottom line here
is, again, you can do
very small changes that
can have pretty large effects.
There's other types of
examples that government use,
or where governments use--
not just-- another
example would be
sending out letters for people
to pay their taxes, which
essentially are like
reminders, or often appealing
to people's sort of
prosociality in various ways.
But the government
sends you letters.
And there's different
ways in which
you can write these letters.
You could say you
should pay your taxes,
or everybody's
paying their taxes,
or good citizens pay
their taxes, and so on.
And people-- there's a whole
industry of nudged units
where people then try
to figure out what's
the best way of doing that.
And by doing that
in different ways,
that can have a pretty large
effect on people's behaviors.
And the governments sort
of love this, because it's
a very cheap thing to do.
And it can have large impact
and change behavior quite a bit.
In this case, in the tax
case, increase revenue
by quite a bit without costing
the government very much.
Because often, [INAUDIBLE]
send some letters anyway.
And they send some more in
some less effective ways
of doing that.
When you think about
the intervention
that I have here on the
slide, the FAFSA one
is essentially just--
the effects almost
surely will be
persistent in the sense of
like, this is a one shot choice,
whether you send your
kid to college or not.
And once you increase
the college enrollment,
which might have some other
issues, but once you do that,
there's going to be
persistent effects.
Because once kids
go to college, that
has effects on their
behaviors and so on.
Now when you're saying
something else, which
is some other
decisions, [INAUDIBLE]
just like about paying
taxes where every year
you get this letter from the
government that sort of tells
you you should pay your taxes,
maybe the first time it works.
Maybe the second time as well.
But at some point,
you're like, whatever.
I don't care.
That's a great question.
And I don't know whether we
have lots of evidence or not.
I think the governments
would sort of--
I think there's some
research on this
that I just am not
sure I'm aware of.
I think governments or people
would say, well, in some sense,
we don't care that
much about it.
Of course we care.
But it doesn't change the
fact that in the first year--
so we know that in the first
year, it works pretty well.
And there's some things that
work better than others.
Many governments send
some letters or some forms
of mailers anyway.
So what you want to do is kind
of like make sure you optimize,
at least the first or second
time you contact people.
And that might have
some persistent effects
by themselves, even if
you don't re-contact them.
Because once you start
paying your taxes,
maybe then it becomes a habit,
and people do it anyway.
But even if that's
not persistent,
governments would say, well, if
that gets people to pay taxes
more at least once or
twice, that's worth
sort of the money spent.
[INAUDIBLE] somebody essentially
needs to design this letters.
There's like, templates
of what you can use.
And that's essentially
very cheap to do
and has pretty large effects
at least in the short run.
I think [INAUDIBLE] correct,
which is sometimes it's like,
some effects--
it's just information versus
some things about making
you feel bad, or social norms.
I think the information things--
if you think people just forget
stuff-- for example, if people
forget to get their flu shot
and so on, you should probably
send reminders and so on
and get them to do that.
If there's sort of these social
norms, or sort of [INAUDIBLE]
makes you feel bad in some
ways, maybe those things
are maybe more likely to
potentially at least go away
once you do it like 17
times, because at some point,
people are like, yeah, whatever,
the same letter I got always.
And I haven't paid
my taxes last time.
I'm not going to
pay them now either.
It's additional assistance
in completing and filing
applications.
So essentially, it's not--
so the financial aid
is always available.
It's just who takes
advantage of financial aid
depends on how easy
you make it to people,
and whether you
support them, provide
some support in completing
and filing applications.
There's also [INAUDIBLE] with
that where essentially, once
you do your taxes,
essentially, it already
prefills you the forms,
which is even easier to do.
But essentially, this falls
under the category of making
things easy for people.
And that can sort of change
behaviors quite a bit.
But the key part
in the nudges is--
and let me get back
again to the definition--
is that there's no
financial incentives.
So this part here is without
imposing any coercion,
or without paying any kind
of material incentives,
or at least, only very,
very small incentives.
There's a bit of a question
how to define that.
But once I pay you $1,000 to
go to college or whatever,
subsidize you, that's
not a nudge anymore.
Or once I'm taking away certain
options from you, [INAUDIBLE]
eliminating choices
from your choice set,
again, that's not a nudge.
That's something else.
That's changing your choice set.
This one is-- nudges
are explicitly
about keeping people's choices
fully free and available,
but making it easier for them
to make a certain choice.
Presumably, a choice
that's desired
in some ways by
the social planner,
or about people's
plans for their future.
So anyway, there's a large
sort of set of examples
of different nudges and so on.
And they can be
fairly effective.
Of course, not for
everybody and not
for the fraction of people
who are swayed by these nudges
is not huge, in part because
if you think about it,
essentially people need to
be marginal in some ways.
If people just
really, really don't
want to go to college because
it's too expensive for them,
or whatever for other
reasons, or if people really
want to go to college
anyway, the nudge
will not change that behavior.
Whether somebody fills
out the form or not
doesn't really matter.
But if somebody is
sort of like, ah,
maybe I should send the
kid to college or not,
but now [INAUDIBLE]
form and then
they forget about it
and so on and so forth,
for that kind of
people, there will
be potentially large effects.
But sort of then by
definition, in some ways,
the fraction of people
who are actually marginal
will not be huge.
But again, since the costs
tend to be extremely low,
it tends to be very much
cost effective to do so.
Now again, sort of
previewing a little bit what
comes in the policy lecture
is, so minor interventions
can have large effects.
But nudges can often
achieve sort of--
in some cases,
nudges can achieve
unambiguous improvements.
Like, if you send people
reminders and they forget
to get the flu shot, and
now they do the flu shot,
or if people don't
take their medication,
and you remind them,
or provide information,
or some other forms
[INAUDIBLE] [? tell ?]
people to take their
medication, it's
pretty clear that that's
making people better off.
But there's also a bunch of
challenges and other situations
which is kind of like--
in some cases, it's
not at all obvious.
Like, which nudge to choose--
are we making
everybody better off?
Are some people made worse off?
For example, should everybody
save for retirement?
Are we pushing people
to save too much?
Should everybody go to college?
Maybe in some ways,
for some people,
it's more suitable than for
others to go to college.
Often it's a huge financial
expense for the family.
And if then the job prospects
are not necessarily better
compared to not
going to college,
then it's not clear
that one should do that.
There's also some evidence
or some concerns about nudges
making people feel bad.
So you get these
letters that says
you're destroying
the environment,
and [INAUDIBLE] all
these sad faces,
and you're worse
than your neighbors,
people might just
feel bad about it.
And we should put
some weight on that.
If you send these letters
to 1,000 households,
and 50 households
or 20 households
change their behavior
in certain ways,
but 300 households
feel bad about it
because they feel uncomfortable
getting these nudges,
or you get all these phone calls
and spam about the environment
from sending too
many letters, we
should put some weight on that.
And then it's like, then
there's some trade offs.
It's not like entirely free.
And then there are some
costs and benefits of that.
There's also some
questions about which self
should we respect.
We talked about
this a lot before,
which is if one self
wants to be very virtuous
and exercise a lot and
so on, and the other one
wants to sit on the
couch and watch TV,
or if one self wants to smoke
and the other one does not,
it's not obvious that we
should respect the long run
self compared to the short run
self that wants to just enjoy
themselves, and so on.
And sort of now there's
tricky issues [INAUDIBLE]
are we actually making
people better off or not.
And we'll get back to these
issues in the last lecture,
which talks about policy.
Any questions on this lecture?
This is actually lecture
20 about malleability
and inaccessibility
of preferences.
This is, in a way, a
more radical deviation
from neoclassical economics.
Because so far, we
have always said,
people know their preferences.
People have certain beliefs.
Their beliefs might
be wrong, and so on.
But crucially, people
knew what they were doing,
and they were deliberately
making certain choices.
And whether their
preferences were perhaps
including present bias, or
social preferences, a reference
dependence or the like--
but these preferences
were given and fixed.
And people knew what
those preferences are.
Now we're going to deviate
from that and think about
[INAUDIBLE] evidence that
people might not actually A--
these preferences
might be malleable.
And B, people might
not even understand
why they want what they want.
And sort of the
preferences are sort
of quite mysterious to people.
And it's quite easy in some
ways to manipulate people
in some ways, without them
even understanding it,
knowing about it.
So I tell you about some very
fascinating psychology work,
which is called-- the paper is
called "Telling more than we
can know" from Nisbett
and Wilson, which
is a classic paper
in social psychology.
And then we're going to talk
a little bit about willingness
to pay, and then
the paper by Ariely
et al on coherent arbitrariness,
which you were supposed
to read for today.
OK.
So let's step back a little
bit, and talk about the Nisbett
and Wilson paper.
So this is-- so
many questions-- you
might have any questions about
cognitive processes underlying
our choices, evaluations,
judgments, and behaviors.
You might wonder,
why do you like
a certain person versus not?
What do you like about them?
And why do you like this
person and not another person?
And why you're friends with this
person versus somebody else?
And why do you like
Math versus English,
and so on and so forth?
How did you solve
a certain problem
once you were sort of asked
to solve some problems?
How did you come
up with a solution?
Why did you take this
job, or why did you
take this class,
versus another class?
And you might sort
of say, well, I
like this one and not that one.
And I really like sort
of like computer science,
versus math versus economics.
But when you then ask
[INAUDIBLE] yourself
for others, why exactly do you
like that one, versus something
else?
You'll realize quickly that
people often don't quite
have a good answer
to those questions.
And Nisbett and Wilson's
fairly provocative paper
says, essentially, we have no
idea where these preferences
are coming from.
And we're just making stuff up.
And so let me give you
some examples of that.
The first example is
what's called Maier's
two-string problem from 1931.
This is [INAUDIBLE] one of these
classic psychology experiments.
The experiments
works as follows.
There's two cords
hung from the ceiling
of a lab with many objects, such
as poles, ring stands, clamps,
pliers, and extension cords.
Subjects are now asked--
are told that a task is to
tie the two ends of the cords
together.
So there's two cords
hanging on the side
of each side of the room.
And subjects are supposed to
tie these two cords together.
The problem is that the
cords are placed far apart
from each other,
such that subjects
can't, while holding onto
one cord, reach the other.
So you can't just
take one cord and then
sort of like try
to reach the other,
because it's too far away.
And so there's all these
different objects in the room.
And subjects are sort of trying
to figure out how to do this.
And so then they usually come
up with one or two solutions
that are not really solutions,
because it doesn't really work.
So they can get [INAUDIBLE]
like extension cord,
they use the pliers, and so on,
and the clamp, and some ring
or whatever.
And it just doesn't work.
And then they sort of
try it and keep trying,
but it doesn't really work out.
And then they're told
to do it another way.
And then Maier,
the experimenter,
walks into the room at some
point, or walks around,
and essentially,
accidentally-- this
is sort of like on purpose
of course-- accidentally puts
some of the cords in motion.
And subjects then very
quickly afterwards figure out
the solution within
the next 45 seconds.
Of course, the
reasoning here is,
why they figure it out is
because now the cords are
put in motion.
And subjects sort of
figure out how to do this.
And what you're supposed
to do is essentially
put the cords in motion.
And once you put
them in motion, you
can essentially reach them
both and then put it together.
I have a video here.
I'm a little traumatized
the last time
where it didn't work out.
So I'm not sure [INAUDIBLE].
Now I don't even see it.
So maybe let's just skip it.
But you can watch
the video of that.
It's the first two and
a half minutes video.
[INAUDIBLE] see anything.
But there's a video that sort of
demonstrates this task that you
can sort of just skip this.
So now then afterwards,
people are asked, well,
how did you come up with the
idea of using a pendulum?
And people then have all
these like explanations.
Well, it just dawned on me.
It was the only thing left.
I thought about all
these different things.
And at the end, I came up
with this other solution,
which is using these
strings as a pendulum.
Or I just realized
the cord would swing
[INAUDIBLE] the weight on it.
So what the solution
at the end is like,
you put the plier on one of
the cords and then swing it.
And then you sort of
use the other one.
And then you could
put them together.
There's one Harvard psychology
faculty subject, in fact,
had the following
explanation, which
is, having exhausted
everything else,
the next thing was to swing it.
I thought of the situation
of swinging across a river.
I had an imagery of monkeys
swinging from trees.
This imagery appeared
simultaneously with a solution.
The idea appeared complete.
Now of course, the
problem here is that--
the problem here is
that's all bullshit.
Because the reason why people
come up with a solution
is because, as I told you, Maier
was walking in and accidentally
putting the cords in motion.
And there's
differences in timing.
Sometimes they would come
in earlier, sometimes later.
And every time the
experimenter walks in,
people would sort
of accidentally
then figure it out,
and then come up
with these elaborate
explanations.
And the reason why
we know that this
is because of the
experimenter are coming in
is because if the experimenter
doesn't accidentally come in,
and puts the cords in
motion, then essentially,
people are not figuring out.
So we know the true
causal effect here
is the experimenter
coming in and suggesting
a solution to people.
But people then make
up all these stories,
including like the
monkeys swinging
from trees, how they came
up with a solution, which
is clearly not how they
came up with the solution.
The reason why they came
up with the solution
is because Maier
touched the strings.
OK.
Now there's a
second example here,
or three examples in total.
So let me tell you
about example number--
or let me ask first, is there
any questions about this study?
By the way, you should
lower your hands,
if you asked
[INAUDIBLE] previously,
like [? Brian ?]
and [INAUDIBLE]..
Unless you have have
additional questions.
Let me tell you the
second study now.
This is a study by
Latane and Darley,
which is, I told you
this a little bit
about [INAUDIBLE] these are
the impacts of bystanders
and witnesses on
helping behaviors.
I told you about the story
of the Good Samaritan before.
This is sort of a similar study.
And this is
essentially a situation
that's, again, created
by social psychologists.
It's not a real
situation, but people are
meant to think that it's real.
And so here, the more
people over here, someone
in another room,
having what sounds
like an epileptic seizure,
the lower the probability
that any given individual
will rush to help.
And you get similar results
for individuals' reaction
to dangerous-looking
smoke coming out
of the ceiling of a room.
So like there's people
in the experiment.
And they have smoke
coming out in a room.
And the more people that
are there, the less likely
is any given person, perhaps
because they're freeriding
is to actually do
something about it.
And this looks kind
of very dangerous.
But nobody does anything,
because essentially
other people are also
not doing anything.
Now when you then ask
people afterwards,
you know, what
influenced your choices?
And essentially, when you ask
them directly and tactfully
and bluntly, you always get the
same answer, that essentially,
they think their behavior
had not been influenced
by the other people present.
They think you're like--
for whatever reason,
they didn't do
anything, or maybe they
thought it wasn't so bad, or
there wasn't really danger,
or whatever.
But of course, these are
randomized experiments.
We know that some
subjects were influenced
by the presence of other
people, because precisely,
the experiment was
creating that variation,
and it affected
people's behavior.
[INAUDIBLE] people essentially
just don't understand that,
and sort of then come up
with other explanations
of why they do or did
what they, in fact, did.
And number three is
sort of very similar.
These are called erroneous
reports about position effects.
These are studies
where certain items
are positioned in different
ways, to get people to--
when people were
evaluating them.
So passerbys were asked
to evaluate some clothing.
And they were asked about the
quality and the preferences--
the quality of certain
goods and people's
preferences between
different goods.
And the way this
experiment was set up--
and this is sort of essentially
like a marketing experiment
if you want--
essentially, there's a
pronounced left-to-right
position effect.
The rightmost object
was heavily over-chosen
in these experiments.
And that's in some sense
irrelevant why that's the case.
But essentially, from
previous experiments,
we know that essentially
the rightmost object
is most likely to be chosen,
perhaps because people
look at it first.
[INAUDIBLE] look at it last
and so on, it doesn't matter.
What's important
for our purposes
is that the rightmost object
is most heavily chosen.
People like that object the
best in these experiments.
And then there's going
to be randomization
in the positioning
of experiments.
And people are then
asked, well, why
did you choose this
sweater versus another?
And no subject
whatsoever ever mentions
the position of the
article in the room,
and virtually all
subjects denied
it was, when asked directly
about the possible effect
of the position of the article.
And people come up with
all these explanations.
It's like, green is really
always my [INAUDIBLE] favorite
color.
And this sweater
is really fluffy.
And this and that.
And I really like it
for reason x and y.
Of course that's
true for some people,
but we know that at
least some people must
be swayed by these
position effects,
because we set up an experiment
to precisely do that.
And then that essentially
swayed behavior
in a very predictable way.
So essentially, there
are these determinants
on people's preferences
of behavior,
that people do not
seem to understand.
OK.
So let me summarize
what did we learn.
So there are many instances in
which subjects have no idea why
they choose what they choose.
And then people--
[INAUDIBLE] can read
this more in this paper,
which I think is a
beautiful paper--
people appear to
make up stories that
are based on their a priori,
implicit causal theories.
What I mean by that,
essentially, they
have some theory of why
they do certain things.
And when you ask them,
then, OK, well, why
did you do what you just did?
People will sort of
come up with some ways
of justifying
[INAUDIBLE] in some ways
their behavior, based
on some theories
that they had about themselves.
And sort of--
I always like fluffy
sweaters, and therefore you
choose the sweater.
Of course, it happens to
be the only [INAUDIBLE]
sweater if it's [INAUDIBLE] on
the right versus on the left.
But people then sort of have
their ways in which they then
explain what they do based on
essentially things that they
sort of essentially make up.
Any questions on this
before I move on?
And I encourage you to read
the paper, more for fun
than for anything.
It makes you kind of
wonder quite a lot
in why you do what you
do, and why you prefer
certain things versus others.
So let's briefly talk about
two experimental design
tools, which will be useful
for the coherent arbitrariness
paper.
One is what's called the
strategy method, which
you already came
across a little bit.
And the second one
is what's called
the BDM, the
Becker-DeGroot-Marschak
procedure for
eliciting valuations.
I'll try to be quick.
So we're often interested in
behavior in rare contingencies.
So often, we may
ask the question,
how would people behave in
many different contingencies?
Some of them are
often quite rare,
that don't happen very often.
And why do we care about
such contingencies?
Well, sometimes we
just care about them
like [INAUDIBLE] it's
inherently important
how people behave or prevent
certain contingencies,
disasters, earthquakes,
droughts, et cetera.
We care a lot
about these things,
even if they're sort
of rarely happening.
So we kind of want
to know how people
behave in certain situations.
But events and
rare contingencies
also can affect, on top of that,
events in likely contingencies.
Here's a simple example.
If your roommates think
you'll punch them in the face
if they borrow your stuff
without asking them,
they will not do it.
Of course, hopefully, you are
not punching your roommates,
and I very much do not want
to encourage you to do so.
But here, the key part
here is that punching
is rare but important, precisely
because you might do so in case
they misbehave, they will
not borrow your stuff
or steal your stuff
in the first place.
So essentially, sort of
these [? equilibrium ?]
or rare contingencies
might be quite important,
not because we think they
actually happen very often,
but they sort of discipline
behavior in other cases.
Now, what's [? known ?]
as strategy method?
Well, the strategy
method helps you
to elicit behavior in many
potentially rare circumstances
by asking subjects
what they would
do with a choice implemented
if the circumstances arises.
That is to say, I'm asking
you-- for many different cases,
I'm going to implement
one of those cases.
And that's going to allow me to
be [INAUDIBLE] [? compatible ?]
in various ways.
So since the decision does
count if the contingency occurs,
subjects have an incentive
to choose correctly
for each contingency.
That is to say, I could say,
suppose this is what we're
doing in class in some sense.
We talked about
social preferences.
I said, you know, I'm
asking you to make a choice.
I'm going to only pick one of
you to implement that choice.
And you have the incentives
now to answer truthfully,
because it could always be
the case that your choice will
be implemented.
And so that allows then the
experimenter, me in that case,
to generate a lot of data from
one simple experiment, where
essentially, you
can give a subject
many different
decisions, and then say,
only one of your
choices will actually
be implemented for sure.
Or you can ask many people
the same question and say,
[INAUDIBLE] only one of
you, or one of your choices
will be implemented.
And so then that's essentially
incentive-compatible,
because it can always be that
your choice is the one, or one
of the choices is
the one that counts.
And when you look at sort
of experimental evidence,
it seems to suggest that the
strategy methods are asking,
essentially, if I can ask you--
so there's experiments where
I can ask you 100 different
questions, and only one of them
will be implemented, versus
a different group would
be asked-- a randomized
group would be asked only one
question.
It turns out that people
actually answer in experiments
these questions pretty similarly
in both of these cases.
So that's to say the
strategy method seems
to elicit individuals' true
preferences pretty well.
Sorry.
[INAUDIBLE] messed up.
But I think that's fine.
So what's now the
Becker-DeGroot-Marschak
procedure?
It's essentially
a version of that,
which looks something like this,
which is, people are asked--
[INAUDIBLE] so
what the goal here
is to understand people's
willingness to pay for a good.
So subjects are told
that a price for the good
will be randomly selected.
And the price goes from like
$0.50 to like, say, $10.
For each of these prices,
the person is asked,
do you prefer buy versus
not-buy in these options.
And so then, I ask you to
fill out the entire form.
Tell me, for each of these
prices, what do you want to do?
If the price is $3,
what do you want?
If the price is $1,
If the price is $10,
what do you want?
And then I'm going to afterwards
then pick a price and say, OK.
Now the price is $3.50.
And now I'm going to just look
at like, what did you actually
say, and whatever
your choice was then
for that specific price is
going to be implemented.
Is that clear?
Now, just to be clear what
the problem is that we're
trying to overcome here--
suppose I'm trying
to sell you a mug.
Or suppose I have this mug here.
I'm saying, would you
like to buy this mug?
It's a very beautiful mug
with lots of trees on them.
I'd like to sell it to you.
And I'm eliciting your
willingness to pay.
What's the problem
that arises from just
asking you this directly,
without the BDM procedure?
What problem-- what is the BDM
procedure sort of helping with?
So if you go to a
marketplace, or try
to bargain with me on
this mug, which again,
it's a beautiful mug--
you might want to
shade your valuation.
You might be willing
to pay $5, but you're
going to say $2, because you
are hoping to get a bargain
and get [INAUDIBLE] a
cheap price from me.
Right?
And the key part here is
that you are essentially
hoping that your willingness to
pay whatever you are offering
me will essentially
change whatever price I'm
offering the mug to you.
Notice that that's not the
case here in the BDM procedure.
In the BDM procedure,
whatever you say
is independent of the actual
price that's implemented.
I'm saying,
essentially, I'm going
to randomly pick one of
those 10 or 20 prices here.
And you're going to tell me, for
each of those prices, what you
want, either buy or not buy.
And your choices are-- since
I'm randomizing afterwards,
which price selection
you're going
to pick, your choices
are irrelevant for which
of the actual
prices are selected.
And so now essentially
get around this issue
about people shading or
essentially underreporting
their willingness to pay.
Precisely that's what makes
it incentive-compatible.
And that's essentially what's
called the BDM mechanism.
That's what many economists
use in many, many experiments.
There's another
version of what's
called the BDM which is a more
straightforward version of it.
Notice here you have
to ask 20 questions.
Ask would you like to pay--
would you like to buy it
for $0.50, $1.00, $1.50,
$2.00, and so on and so forth.
Another version of this is, I'm
asking you straight up what's
your willingness to pay.
And the bid is then compared
to a price determined
by a random number generator.
I'm just saying, like, tell me
what your willingness to pay
is.
Then I'm going to do like
a random number generator.
If the subject's bid is
greater than the price that's
generated by the random
number generator,
he or she pays the price,
not the announced willingness
to pay, and receives the
item being auctioned.
If the subject's bid is
lower than the price,
he or she pays nothing
and receives nothing.
And so now here again, the
final price the person must pay
is independent of what
the person indicated
as your willingness
to pay, which
essentially solves the
incentive compatibility issue.
Think of like this
version that I
have on this line as just a
more efficient way of eliciting
the question that's
on the previous slide.
This is essentially
exactly the same thing,
except for that it's a
more efficient thing to do.
The problem with this version,
often, is comprehension.
People get confused.
Or people tend to still
try to bargain and give
like lower willingness to pay.
So sometimes, this
version works better
because it's much
easier, much transparent,
when we say, here's a price,
do want to buy it or not,
versus and so on.
While here it's people are sort
of [INAUDIBLE] because they're
used to, essentially,
bargain, they
tend to sort of under-report
at least sometimes.
Any questions on this?
So now I'm also going
to skip this video.
It's a fun video.
Who knows the story of
Tom Sawyer and the fence?
I think it's in
the readings, no?
Tom Sawyer was misbehaving.
He was essentially punished
to paint the fence.
He really didn't want to do it.
But then his friend comes
along, and essentially,
he sort of tricks his
friend into thinking
this is really like
such a fun task,
and it ends up
being essentially,
the friend even paying him
for painting the fence,
and he not having to do it.
And the point of the
story, of course,
is that people's willingness to
pay is malleable in the sense,
like, even to the extent
that people don't even
know whether they're willing
to pay for something,
or you have to pay them
something to do it.
And so essentially,
people's preferences
are inherently malleable by
the way they're being marketed,
or the way they appear to
them, or being sold to them.
You can watch the video in
the slides if you download it.
For whatever reason this
is not working on Zoom,
at least for now.
So stepping back a
little bit-- so overall,
so far we talked about
two key components
of individual decision making.
Utility functions-- what people
want and what they care about,
and beliefs-- how people
perceive themselves
and patterns in the world.
And so understanding
these, of course,
is important because that
determines people's choices.
Now so far, we have
always sort of pretended
and said people's preferences
and beliefs are always
sharply--
people are always sharply aware
of what they want and believe
that costs [INAUDIBLE].
For example, a
homeowner might have
reference-dependent
preferences, but they know
what their preferences are.
There might be some issues
about how the reference
point is determined, but the
preference is the function.
The functional form is
always fixed, and it's known.
A person might have the
wrong theory of the world,
but she always has some
beliefs in mind, what
she uses to make those choices.
Or a smoker might
act suboptimally,
but he always has a
fully specific strategy
in mind for all his current
and future decisions.
So people-- the
smoker might sort of
have some issues
with present bias,
or some wrong beliefs in
some ways or the other.
But the utility
function was always
assumed to be fixed and known.
Now we're going to
deviate from that.
If you think about it like,
what are your preferences,
and what do you like and
what do you not like--
in many cases, we
actually don't know.
And in many cases,
people sort of just
make things up as they go along.
So that's to say, like,
people are essentially
making some choices.
And this one of the
examples that I showed you
from earlier--
the three examples
that I showed you first,
where people are just
induced to make certain
choices one way or the other,
depending on their
choice environment,
social influence.
In Tom Sawyer's case,
what he tells his friend.
His friend is now willing to
pay to paint a fence, which
actually is a punishment.
So people's preferences
seem inherently malleable.
And so that's what this paper
about coherent arbitrariness
is very much about.
And so if you think about
it, in some ways, almost all
of economics, and any class that
you have taken, the professor--
or in any book, people will
write down the utility function
as if that's some truth that
we know about the world.
And this is what the
utility function looks like.
But if you think about
it, in many cases,
actually, we don't know
what is the utility
function [INAUDIBLE].
If somebody asked
[INAUDIBLE] particular
about new goods, who knows what
our preferences actually are.
So for example, if you say,
you're trying to buy a monitor,
and there's like a 30 inch
monitor versus a 24 inch
monitor, who knows how much
you're willing to pay for that.
Maybe $50, maybe $100,
maybe $20, maybe nothing.
It's very hard to sort
of figure this out.
And sort of when asked to
make these kinds of decisions,
people tend to sort of
construct their preferences
on this stuff.
They essentially make stuff up.
And so because of
that, because people
are sort of fundamentally
in some ways
unsure about their
preferences, this construction
of their valuation is very
much easily manipulated
by, often, cues that should
be really irrelevant.
And so one example that I
showed you a little bit--
I think in the second
class, or from the survey,
is what's called anchoring.
This is also in the Ariely
paper, which essentially
is, what they were
doing is, they
were asking people
about their willingness
to [INAUDIBLE] their
Social Security number.
And then afterwards,
their willingness
to pay for different things,
about like, wine, design books,
chocolates, and so on.
Notice that these are
somewhat unusual things
that people wouldn't
necessarily buy every day.
And essentially what
you see is people
who are in the highest quintile
of their Social Security
number--
this is like year number five--
have much higher
willingness to pay.
And this is also all
incentive-compatible
[INAUDIBLE] methods
essentially of using
some form of BDM methods.
People's willingness to pay is
way higher when their Social
Security number--
the last digits of their Social
Security number are higher.
Now of course, that
shouldn't be the case.
Your Social Security number has
nothing to do with your tastes
for wine.
Because that's [INAUDIBLE]
explicitly random.
Yet, people are
easily manipulable.
And the difference in sort of
valuations is like, [? huge. ?]
If you happen to have a
low Social Security number,
or the last digit are low, then
you are willing to pay $11.73.
If it's high, you're willing
to pay like three times or even
more as much.
So the huge differences show
that people are pretty easily
manipulable.
Now notice that these
questions that I asked here
are sort of somewhat
unusual sort of items.
This is not asking
like how much are
you willing to pay for
food at the food truck,
or whatever stuff that you
do every day, or for a pizza.
Because there, people
kind of know already
how much they're paying anyway.
And if I just ask you
something else that's
different from the market
price, people probably
would not want to be
paying like $30 for it,
even if their Social Security
number tends to be quite high.
Now, Ariely et al go
further with this.
In some sense they have sort
of more radical deviations.
So they elicit people's
willingness to accept.
And this is how
much they have to be
paid to endure an
unpleasant sound
for a different length of time.
Now, why did they pick
like an unpleasant sound?
In part, because they
could provide people
like a sample of it.
In part because people don't
have any experience with that.
It's completely unclear
how much you are
supposed to be willing to pay--
are willing to accept
for listening to a sound.
So there's no price or
market price for it.
And people sort of had
to sort of in some ways
rely on their own
preferences for that.
And then they know it's very
easy to change the quantity.
You can do like 10 seconds,
30 seconds, 50 seconds.
It's very easy to
manipulate that.
Now what is the procedure?
Subjects we're listening to a
30 second sample of the noise.
Then there were answering
whether they hypothetically
would be willing to listen
to the noise for another 30
seconds for x cents.
And then they were
asked their willingness
to accept for 10, 30 and
60 seconds afterwards.
Notice that number two is
only a hypothetical question,
and is essentially entirely
irrelevant for number three.
Sorry.
This is supposed to say
number three, not number one.
So number two here is like
completely irrelevant.
This should really have
no effect whatsoever
in affecting your willingness
to accept for the 10, 30 and 60
seconds.
Again, this is just a
hypothetical question
that really does not
matter, and is not
going to be implemented at all.
And then the
experimental variation
here is that x was
varied across subjects.
Now, why would x matter?
What's going on here?
What's the experiment
trying to do?
People are very unsure about
what their valuation is.
So now what they do
is, essentially, they
use the x-- the amount that's
offered as like an anchor.
The same way as in, usually in
markets, when you go to a store
and look at how much
do certain things
cost, and you don't know the
quality of the underlying
items, often people sort of
try to infer quality or lack
of quality from the price.
And if we sort of say,
if I'm telling you
I'm going to pay you
like $100 for this,
it must be really,
really painful.
So people try to sort of
infer in some ways something
from that.
Now notice that this is
explicitly hypothetical.
[SOUND]
And so on.
And so really it
shouldn't matter.
If people were sure about like--
I just played you the sound.
So you shouldn't be able
to tell me how much you
like it or dislike it.
So this should
really be irrelevant.
But people seem to sort of
essentially just not really
know what's appropriate,
or how much they're
willing to accept
or not to do that.
And x essentially is sort of
then anchoring [INAUDIBLE]..
OK.
So now we get these
somewhat messy graphs.
Can somebody explain to
me what this graph shows?
What do we find?
These are [INAUDIBLE]
certain subjects.
And then there's like
10 seconds, 30 seconds,
and 60 seconds here.
So people are always--
for each of these lines,
on average, at least,
willingness to accept
goes up, in the way
you expect, in the sense
of, for more time, people
are asking for more.
That's very reasonable.
So 30 seconds, presumably,
are worse than 10 seconds.
And 60 seconds are
worse than 10 seconds.
But the levels seem to
be completely arbitrary.
Essentially, giving
people a high anchor
increases the levels by
a lot for each duration.
And giving people a low anchor
decreases their willingness
to pay at least a little
bit compared to no anchor,
and surely compared to
the [? high anchor. ?]
That is to say--
and this is sort of where
this term comes from,
coherent arbitrariness,
which is, essentially, people
seem to be coherent
in the sense of like,
once you fix a certain
level, based on that level,
if you ask them, OK, if you
tell me about 10 seconds
and I ask you about 30
seconds, about 60 seconds,
this demand curve or
supply curve, if you want,
looks pretty reasonable.
But the actual
level to start with
is completely arbitrary,
because I can essentially
manipulate you by quite a bit.
Look at the differences
in magnitudes.
This is like 50 versus 30.
That's almost like
twice as much,
depending on just this
[INAUDIBLE] anchor.
And there's sort of
different rounds in that
that you can sort of do
this one way or the other.
And this is like essentially
increasing or decreasing,
starting in 10 seconds
versus-- and then going up.
People's willingness to accept
goes up the longer it is.
Or if you start with
60 seconds and go down,
essentially, people's
willingness to accept
goes down the shorter it is.
So the direction is
very much coherent.
The direction of
essentially this sort
of change in terms of
relative to duration
is very much coherent.
The level seems
very much arbitrary.
And so this is where the
title of the paper comes from.
Arbitrariness, essentially,
people's willingness to accept
depended strongly on x.
For x equals 50, the
willingness to accept
is like about $0.59 on average.
For x equals 10,
it's only $0.40.
But it's also coherent
in very sensible ways.
Their willingness
to accept are highly
sensitive to the
duration in the--
very much in the
expected direction.
Longer is always perceived
to be more painful.
OK.
So how do we think about this?
Well, so one, preferences can
be influenced by relevant cues.
For instance, [INAUDIBLE]
arbitrary initial question,
or the Social Security
number, or whatever that's
being elicited to start with.
But once people have
stated a preference,
related preferences,
they're like, essentially,
surrounding preferences are
consistent in a sense of like,
if you think listening
to the sound is painful,
asking you to listen to it twice
as long will be more painful.
Therefore, I have
to pay you more
to do that compared to what
you said in the first place.
Any questions or is that clear?
OK.
So now there are
some concerns about x
might be viewed as a hint
from the experimenters,
how bad the sound is.
But you know, people just
listened to the sound
for 30 seconds to start with.
Like, I gave you the
sound for 30 seconds.
I told you exactly what it is.
So in some sense, that seems
like not really a concern
anyway.
But there's also-- the very
end of this experiment,
where x was generated
by the last two digits
of the subject's
Social Security number,
and explicitly so, and still
there was a correlation between
essentially x and subjects'
willingness to accept,
which really shouldn't
be in any other--
in the absence of such
anchoring effects.
Are stakes too low?
I told you about like,
$0.30, and $0.50.
Maybe people just
don't care, and so on.
But there's also another
experiment [INAUDIBLE]
10-fold stakes.
And they got essentially
the same results.
So this evidence now is very
much consistent with the idea
that subjects are searching
for their preferences.
They don't quite know
their true willingness
to accept for the sound, and
this is essentially arbitrary.
But they know their
willingness to accept
should relate to each
other in a coherent way.
And in fact, once you fix
the level in some ways,
they are in fact coherent,
or essentially they're
sort of making sense.
They're [INAUDIBLE]
consistent with that,
once you fix a certain level.
Now this is now getting
back to Tom Sawyer.
Now, the paper goes-- so this
essentially is sort of saying,
your level of willingness
to accept for a certain good
that's unpleasant is malleable.
Essentially, I
can manipulate you
to ask for a lower
or a higher price,
depending on some irrelevant
question that I ask you,
for a given thing that is
perceived to be unpleasant.
Similarly, I can manipulate
you to pay more or less
for a certain good
that's perceived
to be a good, something
that you want.
So the stuff on the
Social Security number
that I showed you
previously, going back,
these are all kind of things--
presumably, there's some
use for these things.
Belgian chocolates are
supposed to be delicious.
Red wine, even if
you don't like wine,
you can sell it to
somebody else or something.
These are all things that
seem to be worth willing
to pay for something.
And now essentially,
given that you
are willing to pay something,
or some positive amount for it,
I can manipulate now-- or the
experimenters, in this case,
can manipulate people into
higher or lower willingness
to pay.
And so that's true for
positive or negative things.
Now, what's amazing about
the Tom Sawyer story,
however, isn't the--
it's ain't that work?
It's sort of like, that's the
expression he sort of says
towards the end.
The amazing part
here is that not only
is Tom Sawyer able to manipulate
his friend's willingness
to accept, or willingness
to pay in one direction or--
increase or decrease
it, but he's even able
to flip it from
something that he
hates doing, that's essentially
something that you really
do not want to do, where
essentially one has
to pay somebody to do it,
but instead, his friend
is willing to pay Tom Sawyer
for being able to do it, right?
The friend, now,
instead of like having
the friend to pay for it, you
can say, I have to pay you $10
to do it, the friend is
very happy to say, Tom,
I'm going to pay
you some amount.
So I think he gives him
some apples or some candy
or whatever, so that he
can actually do it himself.
So essentially, what the
manipulation here does
is not only changing
the level for something
that's good or bad, but
it's flipping the sign
from willingness to accept
to willingness to pay, which
is a more radical deviation.
You might sort of think
we know what's good for us
and what's bad for us.
But it seems to be that
what Tom Sawyer is doing
is manipulating sort of the
social perception of the item
or the activity, and that
sort of flips essentially
the sign of the item.
So then Ariely now does that
in a very beautiful experiment
in class.
And I always have wanted
to sort of replicate this,
but I'm not sure I should.
So what he does is, or at
the time, this is with MBAs--
where he did a poetry
reading from Walt Whitman's
Leaves of Grass.
And there, he has an experiment,
where half of the class
is asked hypothetically--
again, hypothetically,
whether they'd
be willing to pay $10
to listen to Ariely
recite poetry for 10 minutes.
So he's like, OK, in
class, some of you
are able to listen to this.
But it could be like--
I think it's outside of class,
because otherwise [INAUDIBLE]..
And are you willing to pay
$10 for attending this poetry
reading?
And I think actually,
Ariely is a very good sort
of story reader.
So it might actually
be fun to listen to it.
But some of you know
to ask hypothetically,
again, are you willing
to pay $10 for it?
The other half then are
asked hypothetically
are they're willing to accept
$10 to listen to Ariely recite
the poetry for 10 minutes.
That's to say, it sounds
like it's pretty painful
to listen to Ariely.
He's going to pay
you $10 to do it.
And are you willing to do that?
Notice that here is
only hypothetical.
These are all
hypothetical choices
that will not be implemented.
So these hypothetical
questions should really
have no effect whatsoever
on what's asked afterwards.
Because afterwards, people
are in fact indicating
their monetary valuations
for one, three or six
minutes of poetry reading.
Now you can already guess
what's happening here is here,
the first condition
is essentially
asking for people's
willingness to pay.
That's essentially
selling the item
as like a good, that's
something that you really want.
And you're sort of
essentially encouraging people
to say, well, you
should be willing to pay
something for it, even as much
as like $10 for 10 minutes.
And that'll [INAUDIBLE]
encourage people,
since they don't quite know,
listening to your professor
is like doing some weird
poetry could be really great,
or could be really bad,
they don't quite know.
But here, essentially, they're
manipulated into paying for it,
while here they're manipulated
into being paid for it,
or asking for money
to be paid for it.
So now, what they then get
is their willingness to pay,
and their willingness
to pay conditions
when the first
condition here, where
they are given the hypothetical
$10 for 10 minutes.
Here, the willingness to
pay goes up and is positive.
And here, it's
negative and goes down.
So what we see essentially
is that not only is it
the case that when you make it
essential, when you ask people
how much are they
willing to pay,
people are in fact afterwards
willing to pay for it.
But notice that everybody
could have just said zero
if they didn't want to pay.
But in addition,
once you sort of
fix their willingness
to pay, the demand curve
is very much
sensible in a sense.
Once you're willing to pay
some amount for one minute,
you're going to
be willing to pay
more money for more minutes.
Essentially, once we
define this good to be
a good for you, or like
this item or this activity
to be like a good
thing for you, people
say more must be
better, and sort of
are willing to pay
more for more minutes.
On the other hand, once the item
is determined as like a bad,
in the sense of this is
really a bad activity.
Listening to your
professor reciting
poetry is really awful, and
you have to be paid for that,
then they sort of say,
well one minute is bad,
but like six minutes
surely is really bad.
And you have to pay me a lot
more for six minutes than
for one minute.
And that's essentially
saying subjects
don't know whether this
reading is good or bad.
But they do know,
essentially, either way,
more requires more money.
And that's essentially exactly
the coherent arbitrariness,
where essentially,
the level or even like
the sign is really unclear.
But once the sign
is sort of fixed,
people behave in
pretty reasonable ways.
I actually don't remember.
I should look it up--
surely in the paper, whether
it's possible in this condition
to actually have--
[INAUDIBLE] so the
[INAUDIBLE] experiment
would surely always ask
you a whole range where
you can always say, between
say, minus six or minus 10,
and plus 10.
Now tell me your willingness
to accept versus willingness
to pay.
So if it's positive,
it's willingness to pay.
If it's negative, it's
willingness to accept.
I think that's what's--
so surely, that's
how the experiment
should have been done.
I would like to think
and hope that's also
how it was actually done.
I don't remember.
This is quite a while ago.
But it's really in
the paper, so I don't
know if anybody remembers.
But I think it's exactly right.
In some sense, the
experiment is very much sort
of manipulating people in
the way of saying like,
well, so the prompt here really
gets you into like, OK, you're
supposed to pay for this.
Now it's kind of a little
bit of a weird thing
to say I'm willing to accept.
Professor says, are you
willing to pay $10 for it?
And then you say,
well, how much are
you willing to pay
for like six minutes?
And then you say, well you
have to pay me like $5,
is a bit of a weird thing to
say and the other way around.
So it's very much sort
of like I think a set up
to sort of generate the effects
that they're looking for.
I think the underlying-- so I
think the underlying essence--
and there are some other
experiments that show somewhat
similar results--
the underlying essence is
right that particularly
for unknown goods,
people's preferences
are very much malleable.
And people just don't
know what they are.
And there's also
some other things.
For example, if you think about,
for example, social activities,
where maybe your friends like
them, or they don't like them,
and people are very much
like-- and this is exactly
the Tom Sawyer example, where
people are very much sort
of malleable.
And you can vastly
shape what people
want versus not in many cases.
And for example, one
example would be like,
there's some very nice
work by Loewenstein
and coauthors that
looks at education.
And sort of, do students
want to study versus not.
And do you want to be a
nerd versus not in class.
And so depending very much
on your environment as a kid,
when you grow up, if
all of your friends
are sort of essentially not
working hard, and sort of
want to be cool, and sort
of do not want to study,
and it's not a cool thing in
your environment to study,
people might just not want that.
But on the other hand, if you
have like five nerd friends who
are all working really
hard, or like, if you're
running around MIT,
studying is a cool thing.
And everybody sort
of is working hard.
And that becomes suddenly very
much like a desirable activity.
So I think more
generally, while this
is a bit of a
contrived experiment,
surely people's
preferences are very much
malleable through their
social environments,
and what they
think others think,
and how they perceive it.
And that can be
[INAUDIBLE] shaped by--
manipulated in certain ways,
and potentially affected.
That could be very much
like a policy angle
if you wanted to change
people's behavior profoundly
without spending
much money, in fact.
Let me-- I think that's
mostly what I have to say.
Let me summarize, and then
tell you about next week
for a second.
So we asked the
question, whether people
have stable preferences.
And it seems to me
that people don't
have clear preferences
for goods and experiences,
and sort of construct their
preferences on the spot.
Now, they're influenced
by environmental cues
that, in a way, that
doesn't necessarily
reflect the true utility
from the good or experience.
And that's very much
also what companies
are doing [INAUDIBLE].
And sometimes, some items are
made really, really expensive.
Like, why is this
thing expensive?
And somehow companies
are able to create
some fads or some way of making
things desirable by just making
them expensive and making
people want them in that way.
That very much
relies on the fact
that people are in
fact sort of malleable.
And you can sort of
introspect and think
about what things in the world
make you generally happy.
What things do you really like?
And what things are sort
of more things that like,
well, other people like
them, and you kind of
get sort of manipulated, or
you get sort of like tricked
into doing that.
And in some sense,
and we'll talk
about this next week a
little bit about happiness--
it's important to sort of
try and figure it out and try
to sort of not perhaps be as
much influenced by others,
and rather figuring out what
you generally and truly like.
So there's a nice
series of experiments
that sort of demonstrate
this coherent arbitrariness,
in very sort of like
clean variation,
and somewhat contrived context.
So you might wonder then, does
it matter in the real world?
Well it's perhaps less
important in settings
where people have experience.
Again, like if I had
done the same experiments
with like pizza, you
know how much you're
willing to pay for pizza.
You know the market price.
And you know also, and so on.
And so there, probably,
your willingness to pay
and your preferences
are very much like set.
But in some other cases,
in particular like new
environments,
[INAUDIBLE] sort of new--
when preferences are shaped--
for example, think about
maybe back when you first
started at MIT, sort of
seeing lots of other students,
when norms are shaped,
people's preferences
are very much malleable and
can be influenced profoundly.
Now, there's not so much
like actual field evidence
in high stakes settings that
are sort of this clean nature.
Having said that,
the examples of,
for example,
environmental-- sorry,
educational choices is perhaps
the most compelling one
because that's
really a high stakes
setting that matters a lot.
But people's preferences
or their choices
are very much malleable.
That's all I have to say
on coherent arbitrariness.
So next time, Monday, we're
going to talk about poverty.
Please read the
paper by Mani et al.
And then on
Wednesday we're going
to talk about happiness
and mental health.
Now, I promised you
a guest lecturer.
And so you know, I was
thinking about what's
a good thing to do.
And so you may have heard
about this at UC Berkeley.
They have llamas come to
campus to make students happy,
and destress them in some ways.
Now, of course, I can't
bring any real llamas.
But what I found,
and you may have
seen this on The Daily Show.
There's this thing
called Goat To Meeting,
where you can essentially
get like a goat or a llama
to come to your
meeting for 10 minutes.
And I did ask for like
a llama to arrive.
But there's apparently
a chance that it
might be a goat or a cow.
So we'll have a visitor
at the end of the lecture.
I think I asked for 2:20,
or between 2:20 and 2:30.
And which we'll have a guest
lecturer that will hopefully
either tell us about happiness
or maybe make some of you,
or at least myself, happy.
That's all I have for today.
I'm happy to answer any
questions that you might have.